wir sind verabredet mit sascha klein vom
verein berliner unterwelten mit ihm
wollen wir einen eindruck gewinnen von
diesem bunker der einmal für 3500
menschen geplant war
das war der plan aber er ging nicht auf
tatsächlich waren es weit mehr die an
diesem ort schutz suchen mussten
und hier unten die bombenangriffe der
alliierten erlebten dadurch diese
unscheinbare tür gehen wir jetzt der
beste schutz gegen vandalismus ist eben
dass der zugang wenig bekannt ist er
gibt mir noch nicht weiter wir müssen
jetzt hier vorne durch zwei weitere
türen
wir haben wir auch direkt die erste
bauliche besonderheit und zwar sieht man
hier ein rampen haus eines von drei
rampen häusern
die hat man experimentell hier eingebaut
weil man vermutet und auch später
festgestellt hat hier können die leute
stolper frei in kürzester zeit und
schneller als mit einem treppenhaus in
den bunker rein 3500 plätze waren
vorgesehen drei ramge häuser drei
aufbauten dazu auf dem platz auf dem
alexanderplatz selber und dann strömten
die leute hier rein
also wir gehen von drei bis fünffache
überbelegung am ende des krieges aus in
der letzten schlimmen phase 45 haben wir
also dann hier 15.000 mehr
manfred greber hat mehrere
bombenangriffe genau hier erlebt als
siebenjähriger flüchtete er mit seiner
mutter bei fliegeralarm die rampen des
bunkers hinab das muss man sich so
vorstellen dass die menschen sehr
aufgeregt mit ihrem gepäck und den
kindern auf diesem punkt zu halten wo
sie wussten dass sie hier in sicherheit
sind und hier in dieser anlage kam
zugute dass man eben den eingang nicht
in form von treppen hatte sondern man
nannte das damals einfach die rutsche
und das würde ich sagen haben teilweise
die kinder sogar aufmuntern zur kenntnis
genommen sind darunter gerannt
in den herbsttagen als ich das erstmal
dann hier drin war
sind tatsächlich aufgrund unmittelbar am
meer eingeschlagen
das war deutlich zu merken dass es einen
richtigen ruck auch unpersönlich im
körper gab das licht flackerte ging
alles ging aber sofort wieder an und im
raum war sozusagen eine stille
eingetreten eine totenstille
bis dann die menschen sich wieder
sammelten und dann flüstert wird
nichts passiert und die kinder wir haben
dann ab teilweise auch auf zu weinen
wo hier links und rechts die räume ab
gehen haben wir den hauptgang auf dieser
etage und wir sehen immer die tür
aufhängung ist leider noch eine tür
vorhanden
diese rennen übrigens mit dem ablauf in
der mitte das ist eine weitere bauliche
besonderheit das ist wie gesagt ein
experimental bau und man hat hier einige
bauliche besonderheiten eingesetzt wie
diese kondensate sie liefen in der mitte
durch ein gitter zusammen und so hat man
die kondensat flüssigkeit aus der
atemluft der vielen tausend menschen
oder auch schweiß oder vergossene
flüssigkeiten hat man also hier
aufgefangen und abgeführt
auch eine ganz neue sache die ich noch
nie da und ein schutz vorgesehen war die
temperatur bei 15.000 menschen dann auch
wirklich höher als gedacht hat dem
gegner umso mehr menschen in einem raum
ohne trennwände ohne klimatisierung
zusammenkommen um so höher ist die
temperatur tatsächlich immer muster mehr
klamotten ausziehen da es noch etwas
überzuziehen
ja das ist auch eine sehr spannende
stelle und zwar ein treppenhaus was
scheinbar irgendwo führt verbindung zum
berliner u bahn system liefen am
alexanderplatz mehrere verkehrswege
zusammen zu einem knoten dieser blinde
tunnel stutzen nachweisen sie wurde
ebenfalls als luftschutzraum als zusatz
kapazität ausgebaut durchtrennen hände
und bänken ausgestattet und am ende des
krieges als der landwehrkanal als die
decke des landwehrkanals gesprengt wurde
das wasser lief in das s-bahn-netz kam
das wasser auch hier in den alexander
ein und hat beide etagen mehr anhänger
geflutet links rechts vom flur waren
solche standard kabinen jetzt hier
untergebracht und die waren bereits mit
toiletten podesten ausgestattet die
haben wir noch eine besonderheit die
ganzen tropfen diese schön schöner hier
im licht an der decke und stalaktiten
das sind feine risse im material wo das
wasser eben durchgedrungen ist und hier
diese stalagmiten gebildet hat und auch
sehr interessant diese spiegeleier
förmigen stalagmiten beim gegenstück ist
in dem bunker hat entstanden wann ist
denn gebaut worden und für sich also im
grunde kann man bis zu 20 30 jahre
zurückgehen der bunker wurde wie viele
andere schutzanlagen von der dimension
eingebautem bereits vorhandenes bauwerk
wir stehen nämlich hier genau genommen
im alten fundament block in einem
breiten fundament blog für eine u-bahn
und hochhaus planungen von peter behrens
unter anderem zur umgestaltung des
alexanderplatzes und diese ganze planung
kam zum stehen auch die ausführungen kam
zum stehen
in 30er jahren weltwirtschaftskrise war
kein geld mehr da und dann hat man erst
mal das ganze die fundamente
zugeschüttet mit kies und sand um 19 36
zum beispiel diese baustelle zu
kaschieren
man wollte die stadt auf hochglanz
polieren und so wurde die baustelle
verschlossen und 1941 bis 43 hat man
sich dieser baugrube in der
nationalsozialistischen zeit und
kriegszeit wieder erinnert an diese
bauhof und als sie dann eben in diesem
bunker ausgefüllt dann hat man hier in
sogenannten holzmöbeln oder aufsätzen
hat man auch immer elektroleitungen hier
durchgeführt die kamen dann entlang der
wand manchmal sehen wir nur holz dübel
wasserleitungen armierungsstahl der da
aus der wand rausschaut zb vorne kleine
schächte durch die man technik
herablassen konnte und auch eine
besonderheit ist hier der tür durchbruch
der ist nämlich immer versetzt wird ja
jetzt hier reingekommen in den raum und
nicht durch den haupt flur und jeweils
waren trug türen eingelassen aus metall
diese metalltüren haben für die
gastlichkeit mit gummidichtung gesorgt
aber auch für druck und später denn wenn
der bombe tatsächlich mal durchschlug
auf diesem fall wollte man ja
eingerichtet sein
dann hätte man hier die druckwelle nicht
gerade durch jagen lassen sondern sie
wer zickzack durch gekommen
und selbst wenn sie durch die ersten
zwei türen und durch dieses zickzack
durch kommt mit jedem dreh um 90°
schwächt sich die druckwelle etwa um ein
drittel ab und die tödliche wirkung
entsprechend sind wir auch schon fast am
ende dieses hauptfluss auf der etage und
das ende markieren heute moderne
betonwände yaman durchbruch zu einem
letzten raum nehmen uns anschauen können
er war ursprünglich mal größer und hier
ist platz geschaffen worden für die
maschine nie hat man direkt nach dem
kriege ausgebrochen diese steine
denn auf diesen sockel starken die
wesentlichen belüftungs und generator
maschinen und das war natürlich alles
benötigt nach dem kriege im herbst 45
wurde diese anlage praktisch entkernt
alles was noch von nutzen da hat man
hier ausgerissen und hier der maschinen
blog passte offensichtlich nicht durch
diese für öffnung
also hat man mit grauen mittelmaß
verbreitert heute haben wir hier
praktisch das ende der bunkeranlage und
das ende auch der erreichbaren flächen
dahinter befand sich mit dem dritten
zugang das dritte rampen haus des
alexander lucas und heute stehen moderne
wagen dahinter ist es nicht geworden die
sich hier rein frisst